after about  six weeks i felt normal mentally  i felt like i was back in control of my  life again like i could keep up and it  wasn't just a tumult of noise and  overwhelming crowds and input  it's about one day on earth for every  day in space in order to  fully feel normal the only last real  lingering effect is uh osteoporosis and  i lost about eight percent of the bone  across my hips and my upper femur  and it's not the hard um brittle bone  it's the soft trabecular spongy bone  that really gives you resistance to  impact  so i'm very susceptible to breaking a  hip or at least i was for the first  while  but my body is reversing the  osteoporosis and  hopefully within about a year about a  year after landing  i should have my bones back to normal  pretty interesting process that your  body reverses it on its own somehow  so it's all it's a long road back to  recovery  but one that is also infinitely worth  every step along the way